the Joe Rogan experience its sober
October supposed to be sober just be
sober guys love yourself but Ari and I
already smoked a cigar that's permitted
guys a cigar cigar but cigars in mine we
got our last thing I'm starting smoking
for this one I took one a Hinchcliffe
cigarettes once for once agent I stole
one of Chappelle's - he gave me a
cigarette before I went onstage it gives
you a buzz cigarette so the boy I hate
anything that's bad for you but the
cigarette does give you an interesting
buzz it is a buzz the in pick Jade did
one of my podcasts we talked about
smoking and it was like so head rush I
would love a cigarette right now
do it you got to get into cigarettes
cigarettes like regularly smokin
cigarettes late in life is de pollo yeah
like when he was 50 that's Jim Marin was
addicted to the laws and edited yeah he
was and he was like he was getting the
point where he couldn't see and getting
physically ill he was eating so many
he'd wake up and they go to sleep with
him in his mouth goddamn like that's is
he off now easy
yeah he's off he's got likes I think
he's got like 14 days off in lozenges
what [ __ ] dumb thing to be addicted
to he must don't really hide the gum
because I want to see if it gives you
the same head rush that it's nothing
stockholm the who it gives you the boys
I remember the dip buzz oh really get
into dipping yeah and that good
like like how white knuckling we're
getting into bed we've all been are you
can choose you can smoke cigars you can
dip you can smoke cigarettes I mean are
you getting into cigarettes I feel like
we're not sober how about just socially
drinking you just can't do it what is it
that mean I mean Bert's on stage in
front of 2,000 people that's social yeah
that's a good point I didn't consider
that but you're right I think if you do
anything with a needle it should be
permitted just because it's kind of
high-risk you know I deserve a little
bit for taking them anal choice where
you drink oh I need to tell you this a
friend of mine his wife is a teacher and
they have a problem in school with
middle school kids who are taking
tampons and they're dipping them in
rubbing alcohol and stuffing them up
their [ __ ] food and they're getting
high as [ __ ] tampons rubbing alcohol
your and your [ __ ] apparently you
just get a tampon up your [ __ ] with
rubbing alcohol just get [ __ ] first
years of going a whole month with no
booze I know how he I know how he works
Bert I bet you can't do it looks like a
squid reach one of my family members
initial results say this is an urban
legend but there are apparently medical
no no no wife who's a [ __ ]
schoolteacher
they have interventions on these kids
there's articles going back for 10 years
saying kids have been doing this talk
about having to break that from your kid
going hey blue pants unless you're ever
anal Chuck did you ever get it
no no we did anal chugs in college and
it was like for eternity where you do a
handstand pour beer in a dude's ass hole
and someone else drinks hatch it in a
cup and then you drink it cleaning did
you do all this on the floor oh you had
to here was one person go anal chug
looks like wait you never know ingested
through your ass no I've never ingested
someone else know that [ __ ] it's
disgusting it's disgusting you can get
dingleberries we can drink beer if we
only do anal ton Josh Martens [ __ ]
that's it are you doing anal tug if
you're a skank first I was the first to
break sober October for sure I would I
would do an anal Chuck if you have a sip
of that I will do an anal chug
[Applause]